all over the world right now public
health and safety groups are turning to
drones to help slow the spread of the
corona virus officials are using them to
monitor public spaces and enforce social
distancing rules a recent study found
that there are nearly 1600 agencies in
the u.s. who now have drones and our air
Barnett is in New York showing us how
they're being used and also the privacy
concerns on Lucas were perplexed as CBS
News captured this drone buzzing above a
New York City Park this month at the
height of the corona virus pandemic
it wasn't the work of New York Police
but instead this frustrated drone
enthusiasts from Queens I couldn't
believe my eyes
xaviar Arthur was so angry at people not
following guidelines to stay home he
offered what he describes as a public
service that's like okay I'm just gonna
make sure that the message gets out loud
and clear
maybe someone listen off as f it may not
have been official but his plan mimics
those of some public safety
organizations nationwide we're not
telling people to get out without
enforcing the four of them having that
go but it's making an announcement for
public safety reason sergeant Tim Aaron
covers Police Department in Daytona
Beach Florida is just one of 43 agencies
in 22 states to receive a donation from
DJI the drone manufacturer gave away 100
devices as part of its disaster relief
program Karen Kafa has also tested but
not deployed other drone back
technologies like measuring body
temperature clear the forward-looking
infrared camera which can detect heat
signatures that technology was meant to
be deployed in Connecticut where the
Westport Police Department planned to
pilot a drone that monitored heat
signatures and tracked distances between
people it can even recognize if someone
coughed but it was pulled over residents
privacy concerns and privacy advocates
in the US are warning of the potential
for abuse you can add the ability to do
facial recognition
you license plate reading thermal
imaging cameras that can essentially see
through walls Jeremy Scott is senior
counsel at the Electronic Privacy
Information Center some people might say
look these extreme measures are just we
use during this pandemic why should we
worry then there should be no issue with
stating that in providing certain
protection saying this information is
only being used in response to the
public health issue will not be used for
other purposes but erinkoval points out
his drones are limited to public spaces
he still has the FAA and local laws that
guide us and it doesn't matter if I'm
using a drone a telescoping antenna or
if I'm flying a kite with a camera on it
I don't have a right to look in your
backyard without a search warrant now
current FAA guidelines require every
single drone to be registered before it
can take flight and that regulation and
registration dictates where and when it
can be operated but here's the thing as
of right now there is no federal
guideline on data collection only best
practices and Tony those best practices
of voluntary yet another area in this
pandemic where an appropriate balance
has to be struck but it could be hard to
find Errol thank you very much